[Music]
nesca is probably one of the greatest
players that's ever played this game
you and us cannot see a single thing as
that gets through more on the board here
he's extraordinarily accurate also
incredibly smart
and he can just exploit every weakness
that you show at him
nazca's find himself with three
different situations there's the man
above though
as he takes care of the first pulls
himself back 15 seconds goes
catches him as he pulls away cleaned up
in laundry and now it's 10 seconds
there's no limit to what he can
accomplish if he's given the right
amount of tools
the smoke's being tossed in that
actually gives the cover away but nest
he just picks the hatch as well canadian
he goes down the c4
mask you terminator being able to
exploit the weaknesses
of other players who are the best in
their field at what they do
is an extraordinarily strong ability to
have in the lobby
he's a he's a goddamn terror but the
problem is
best fights you can't stop him if he
doesn't come down the stairs
that's four finesse can he find a fail
jessie candace
that is the ace from nes the story of
nest is so fabled
again next being just overly active here
he gets one kill and he will not get it
he gets another though in the uk he's
going to come around it looks like ness
will get a double kill
under he's gonna get a 4k
[Music]
like a lot of esports most feral and
ferocious fraggers
andre nescolivera was born and raised in
the fps adoring escarpments
of brazil unlike the majority of his
countrymen however
he didn't get his start in
counter-strike or crossfire
he got it in battlefield they judged
they jogger
evolution
now he did play counter-strike in fact
he
played everything 1.6 go fifa
h1z1 hell even osu but it was in
battlefield that nest
cut his teeth as a competitor coming
back up
buy ice cream we'll be able to get that
first entry frag by the end of 2015
he and his compatriots on intz including
several future siege stars such as julio
were making a mark internationally they
even managed to make their way to the
grand finals of esl one winter
the diffuser trying to get onto the side
but look at this wag is even
going to be able to defend this goes in
for the spray and he's going to be able
to protect the site he's going to be
able to protect
the explosion and he's going to be able
to get the game for infamous the bomb
explodes it's a 3-1 victory on our final
map
and it's a 3-0 victory in this best of
five
unfortunately in a staggeringly close
series
ness and his teammates fell painfully
short of victory
similarly unfortunate was the fact that
by 2016
battlefield was really starting to
crumble as an esport
before long nest began honing his
mechanics in
other more prolific shooters such as cs
black ops 3 and eventually siege
by spring 2016 several of nesc's
teammates
had hopped over to siege full-time and
having stayed on with intz
were making waves in brazil's
competitive scene
midway through the year nesk joined them
and in no time
[Music]
by 2017 latin america had its own pro
league
and ness got the chance to play for
black dragons
on that team he not only placed first in
the regional standings but began
cementing himself as one impossibly
talented fragger
now nesc is here inside of the main
hallway he's gonna peek on around and
grab the head of barrage
that's taking it down for the count nisk
is nuts today geez louise
ness and the way he plays the game just
so well like really in your face
not afraid to push you you know go go go
i'm in your face i'm running up your
main
stairs and i'm just killing the whole
entire team i mean if we think about
nest for a second oh that's gonna be
nesca again
nesk was basically the living breathing
embodiment
of brazilian siege he was rowdy
rambunctious and
unremittingly aggressive he took his
region's famous ferociousness
multiplied it and brought it to rainbow
in a big way
i think nesca is a very flashy player
and i think yeah you kind of see the
bright lights and
that kind of thing with the way he plays
sure i think what gets
ignored is the fact that when ness is in
situations on his own
he still excels and people look at it
and say okay well you've got three
people droning him in okay you've got
people feeding him information on
defense he's able to take that
and use it use it really effectively but
when he's in his own elements
all on his lonesome he still thrives in
that environment
and i think that is the real show of
skill in terms of what nesca is capable
of
he's got the valkyrie cameras in place
to determine if they're going to go in
for the plant he's listening
you do have a bonnet that's nest coming
up from behind he's looking for the
shots and he will dome wesker down
again next being just overly active here
on the attacking squad here for
black dragons now barrage is going to be
inside of that storage room inside of
the connector
this is looking up behind him though
we're choice to be coming around for the
flank but he's got a side his back
turned to it
with the smoke grenades coming out
that's gonna allow nest to progress even
further into the site
and as lion tries to be aggressive
coming on out of the connector yuke will
get him down troy's gonna be on his side
he gets one kill and he will not get it
he gets another though in the uk he's
going to come around it looks like ness
will get a double kill
oh he's going to get a 4k look at that
front black dragon's
nest thanks in large part to nesqu's
earth-shattering individual play
black dragons made the year 2 season 1
pro league finals in katowice where they
faced off against the european
fabian and pangu led superpower that was
penta
needless to say it was a massacre
and now he's got about 40 health and
four members of penta to deal with
this is not going to barrel bid well for
him and zigg will go down by the hip
fire from pangu
map number one goes to penta sports and
last minute live is going to be
he can save this he just needs to play
his cards right this is going to be up
to pengu
or sorry penta all together to try to be
very aggressive go out for the push as
one of his teammates will go to
stop the diffuser now that is one kill
deal going knows that it's happening
here he's got to go for the shot but he
cannot get it we will have penta
win this round they're now going up
three to zero they've got 45 seconds now
they know where he's at they are gonna
collapse on him at the same time some
ghost shots gonna come in you're gonna
see a dual peak here
they're gonna say look for the corners
gonna go one two three they're gonna go
for the shots and he misses one he's not
gonna look for the side but he gets it
and now it's gonna be fabian
getting the win for his team this is the
grand final champions
pence is gonna have time to get this
diffuser down and we are gonna see penta
win this all they are the world
champions right now for season one
still the seed that was nesq's emerging
unbridled aggression
had been planted his roster might have
been bopped but
it quickly became apparent that in the
right circumstances
and with the right support system nesk
could be the best player
in the world and in which case you can't
really get monty to push in further into
the door he'll be crossfired
yeah you know what it's worth there's
the 4k coming out from nest
unfortunately for nesca those conditions
weren't quite presenting themselves
despite being acquired by brke sports
shortly after katowice
that team proved incapable of finding
the synergy that would net them wins
either
within brazil or abroad can he get it
he's gotta move in this could be the
clutch of the century here shuttle he's
got three seconds to go
he can't find him no more it's gonna be
elevate when it gets ram they're going
to the grand finals
but in spite of their inconsistency they
showed tremendous potential
so much so in fact that after barely
qualifying for the sixth invitational at
the start of 2018
nesk and his teammates signed with one
of the biggest orcs to enter siege's
rapidly growing esports scene
liquid grasses
as for liquid's debut at the
invitational well
let's just say that it didn't go very
well it's all up to you
he's coming in to push but inside a
cafeteria sees rizraz rizraz gets it the
aussies do it
and aipac will make it to the
quarterfinals what just happened
mind rick just beat team liquid despite
coming in as
feisty hopefuls liquid put up a
painfully
lackluster performance and weren't even
able to get out of groups
ironically at that very tournament
during the upcoming season's reveal
panel
liquid got their answer some enemies
are invisible but the cbrn
threat unit is rainbow's shield against
those enemies that can kill you with a
single drop of blood
lion was an attacker whose gadget made
defenders essentially susceptible to
wall hacks
unless they stood perfectly still during
executes
and his addition leveled up brazilian
siege like never before
as for liquid they went from aggro to
literal demons and looks like it's a
full stack up on this skylight window to
try and get a plant under cover of smoke
ness will get the entry frag onto levin
who is playing by cocktail sexy cake
gonna get an ads killed you don't see
that often from sexy cake onto yogurt so
that's cocktail completely defanged
hicks though from the flank will get one
bullet and nest
twice again will secure the round and
liquid
all vaulting through the skylight
managed to get a nice swift attack
victory
brazilian latin american meta is the
most aggressive
period they take fights more often than
anybody else they have some of the
probably the best mechanically skilled
players
in any region and because they are so
aggressive
that a lot of teams that aren't used to
that they don't know how to handle it
you just feel like you're getting
overrun being bombarded
and you can't you can't fight against
them because they're going to out aim
you
you can't outpeak them because you don't
know where they're coming from they will
do so
now nasa just walks right up oh two for
nest
we're on match point it's a trade as
renshiro goes to
zig and yogurt is last alive and
unenviable position
he sees one all the way out but sexy
cake will
finish it a 5-0 team liquid made it all
the way to the grand finals of pro
league season 7
where they got a rematch against the
masterful methodical
and since strengthened penta it was a
battle for the ages
brains against brawn the thing is
at first it wasn't a battle at all now a
3v2 i'll make that a 3v1 is psk is down
on the floor
16 seconds though left and 15 seconds
left
unable to drop here and esq pit the
wishful thinking there with a shotgun
and penta
round four on the board and then just as
it looked as if liquid would take a
second beating against siege's european
overlords
they turn the jets on but they are going
to focus a little bit on downstairs
first they want to see what they're
going to have to deal with and
wait looks like a complete dallas
there's a push here for bathroom team
look
gonna get a lot more aggressive than
expected here
wow the like of the smoke we're gonna
get him yes ness will take him out
liquid are running away with this here
as now all the hatch is gonna get open
jonas and kanto though getting a kill
each as they're using
the top of the surface through their
advantage finally nest will land the
headshot on kanto he's very low on
health
3v2 and the diffuser has not been set
just yet nest
will not see the drop does he see the
player that moved away where are you
going pengu
from the top side is bullet taking down
pengu all on us and this is working
the rush play from liquid has been
perfected
and penta did not expect this one here
as diffusers now
and bullet will take down jonas what a
fantastic bit of execution
it's a super enjoyable play to watch the
brazilian because they're so aggressive
and they take so many risks and it's
very
fast so there's always action whereas g2
is notoriously known for being very
boring to watch because they play so
good
but so strict that you're sitting there
just waiting for someone to walk into
their line of sight and get shot right
oh no the push from liquid in the back
penguin will get taken down a sexy kick
rushes
in and there's just still more canned
dallas being shot in jonas cannot see a
single thing as that
get through more on the board here what
a play
it seems like liquid realized we can't
go from the front we'll go in the back
bull with a team kill but you know what
he'll get one more on kanto at least
avengers follow comrade fabian
pass man alive with no c4 to play with
he's got to push up very
close here to win the fight against
bullet he'll take down
at least one player sexy cake low and
health he'll set up on the outside by
the yellow stairs
psk i can't just punch tiny holes open
here
to shoot through as there's only
basically a couple spots that freeman
can
run get the kill bsk will save the round
and round three will go the way
for team liquid round after round nests
roaring cries and rambunctious rushes
led his roster to success until finally
it happened attention bounce but nest
cuts with a knife on the canter a ketty
welcome to the jungle penta sports
that's the first kill and even jonas is
down
two technical kills here for team liquid
maybe uns can be picked up but his
position is precarious
sexy cake takes the ball we'll get the
kill on goga here's the cleanup from
sexy cake two alive penguin fabian
in the making fabian last man alive the
in-game leader on the lion
op is lying here to fight five
good luck fabian everybody from team
liquid concentrating their efforts
you see everybody every single one of
the players here concentrating on the
one kill that they need
have their own yeah they will liquid
latin america goes down
coming out of atlantic city liquid were
on top of the world
not only had they become the first latin
american team
to win an international title they'd
made a true
undeniable dent in penta's dynasty
the single greatest roster rainbow had
ever seen
but as soon as the following season
kicked off ubisoft introduced
pick ban into competitive all but wiping
the undeniably overpowered lion
from the face of pro league people
expected that this would nerf liquid
they didn't expect it to ruin them from
winning pro league
to failing to make it out of groups at
the paris major
liquid fell on hard times but somehow
in spite of liquid's tumultuous results
nesk
continued to put up stellar statistics
cementing himself as siege's hardest
nuttiest carry
mask
unfortunately come the new year liquid's
performance
continued to fall flat this could be it
empire to the semi-finals or liquid
staving off an
elimination going for a rotate down 90
or both sexy cake and pollen trying to
challenge apollo go down
sexy cake last live inside of fountain
point blank range he'll down off
one it's just scyther left alone alive
on ac
with the diffuser down on his window
drone watching constantly pinging
30 hp sexy cake right up against the
window he's running out of time
he's gonna bait it out now he's sticking
on
for a little bit longer two seconds
scyther just need to jump in and shoot
and we'll get it at the very last second
in spite of their occasional spurts of
brilliance liquid
underperformed domestically failed to
qualify for a major
and missed out on two consecutive pro
league finals
and then somehow they made it to the
finals of a dream hack
before trouncing everyone in sight at
oga pit
the smoke's being tossed in that
actually gives the cover away but nest
he just picks the hatch as well canadian
he goes down the c4
rescue terminator and team liquid
they've been flawless the entire
tournament and what a way to finish out
flawless rounds
pack your bags boys you're going to
canada
and yet come the 2020 invitational that
they'd worked so hard to qualify for
liquid didn't just collapse they never
got off the ground
that nitro toss will be affected by the
air jab we can see
m king gets the final kill and then all
that will be
for to do is bullet to move in disable
the diffuser he's got
all the time in the world and mibr will
win
two maps to nil and head into the
playoffs
genuinely almost feel emotional myself
over there because he played so
condemned the worst part is that with
the rival brazilian squad ninjas in
pajamas making it all the way to the
finals
liquid were being outclassed by their
own region
no one doubted that nesc was world class
the question was whether that would ever
be enough to win a championship
and lo and behold liquid leveled up
with kovid moving everything online
liquid were forced to lick their wounds
at home where they spent the next year
securing not only a slew of top three
finishes
but also a sorely needed major win
and this really puts the pressure on
them as nest peeks out
it's all going wrong tim we're in a 4v2
team one
might be our the major as they get shut
down by palu
as liquid are crowned the champions of
the six major
they've done it they've came they've
seen and they have conquered him
going into the 2021 invitational latim
looked stronger than ever
liquid wanted to be the ones to take
home their region's
first world title and despite falling
into the loser bracket early on
made the run of a lifetime and nesk
oh lord did this man dominate
really quick push into the lobby right
here and there you go to take care of it
would have gone six the culver is there
from nask on the window
and the plans will go down there's only
one second left on that there's no way
they can stop that
well the defuse is planted luke could at
least get moringa on
suicide but nest has a freebie dropped
on the hatch doubles up and just
kind of hangs around wait psk in the
meantime going for a big rotate around
the back of admin but don't worry man
nest has got it one more for his tally
and he's hopped over to the other side
for one more
and one way all the way from the window
every single kill
nascar's find himself with three
different situations there's the man
above though
as he takes care of the first pulls
himself back fifteen seconds goes for
the witness catches him as he pulls away
cleaned up in laundry and now it's ten
seconds
if you just kept himself locked in the
corner there might not be anything for
the jackal to pick up ness gets a kill
onto g
or ness another on to achieved this is
turning into the nest
shawdez as he gets another double here
we've got 15 kills on the scoreboard for
him bull or finds one onto moringa shuts
him down calm down
don't go taking pop shots at merc they
can see each other mercs holding the
angle he's cutting off the rotate from
library stairs but the problem is above
best fights you can't stop him if he
doesn't come down the stairs
that's four finesse can he find a fight
jessie candace
that is the ace from nes thanks in
partenesque's sheer animalistic ownage
liquid clawed a path all the way to the
grand finals
where they faced off against ninjas in
pajamas in a bloody bestified
barn burner that will no doubt go down
in history
as one of the greats paolo and psk the
game of the piece sees the longer angle
does connect it on to moosie gets a
second that's what you want coming out
of nesqu
a c4 comes up from pino elsewhere and
brings down the support
in sexy kate those two frags removed
from the board two still remain
on palu and i think here in an op spot
three versus four
you're starting to feel a little bit
nervy at two versus four nest goes big
with a triple kill
that's what you want in round number ten
has got to find one more
pinot the last man left alive if anyone
can do this it's gonna be him
but a one versus four is a very very
tall mountain to climb
rotating back up the solarium stairs but
paulo's got an angle dez
there you go the kill comes in he was on
the bathroom window
he knew exactly where the man was coming
from and that's going to be team liquid
taking our second map of shall we native
now sexy kirk is just constantly
throwing those toxic babe canisters into
the default place what
they try to rush into sight des nesque
despite being on the brink of defeat for
three straight maps
nesk and his teammates rallied round
after round
until finally the tank was empty
and they simply had nothing left to give
has defuser in hand
he finds the shots but paolo cannot find
the kill
out comes the knight shot out by people
that is the round in 2020 brazilian
hearts
were broken but like a phoenix nip
rise from the ashes to claim the hammer
at the sixth invitational 2021.
and honestly it didn't matter that nesk
wasn't able to close the deal
if he and his teammates were going to
fall short of anyone they'd rather it be
to their brazilian brethren what's more
the individual performance he put up
didn't just
hearken to the nest of old it surpassed
it
he's been in the scene for so long so
long
and he's been consistently at the top of
his region and now
you know liquids putting their name in
the in the dirt for uh
for the whole entire global you know
ring of dominance essentially you know
getting second
invites no no small feed no small feat
at all coming out of the event it was
clear
no matter how brightly the limelight had
begun to shine on siege's newest
superstars
brazil's greatest bruiser wasn't going
anywhere
you seem to keep
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else hit
up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages